It's exciting to really change the aesthetics of technology.
If you think about it, people today have to sort of almost choose...
...between aesthetics and beauty and technology.
Those are orthogonal directions.
What's happening now is these two worlds are coming together.
And this class is preparing students...
...to be able to combine the world of aesthetics,...
...specifically expressive fabric, construction and design,...
...and the world of devices and computation.
Fabrics almost mimic materials...
...in a way  where you have various different length scales that all come together...
...to create your overall structure and your final product.
The biggest thing with textiles is that a lot of times,...
...all the different fibers in your clothes...
...are just made of single fiber, maybe there's, like polyester and cotton mixed together.
But at the smallest scale, just that individual strand of fiber,...
...it's just one material.
The meaning of fabrics is changing.
Now, for the first time in history, the fabric is going to be a computer.
The fabrics are going to do for us everything...
...that our smartphones are doing and a lot more.
And the reason they could do a lot more...
...is because they really cover the surface of our body.
And if you want to really understand your health better...
...and get early warnings of changes in your health,...
...we've just published some work on fabrics that could help listen, to help hear;...
...people that have impairments in hearing,...
...fabrics that could listen to the unborn.
And so what we're doing is converting the fabric...
...from just being what it has always been...
...to something that plays a very meaningful role in our lives.